[Musik]
kann man machen wenn ich nicht alleine
das erste mal und es wird nicht
geschnitten also fast alles sagen
aufgenommen
[Gelächter]
am nächsten kam zu spät und war es gibt
ja immer ein thema worüber ich bespreche
dieses mal habe ich auf jeden fall das
thema über nacht lange haare bekommen
hat passiert damit
über die pläne hatte blieb vor drei
jahren ungefähr gehalten mit so was habe
ich schon gemacht hat
aktivkohle oder was ist daran gibt aber
hat weh getan weil ich habe leute auch
wir haben fehler war blieb sondern eher
wie du hast so weit zehn haben nicht so
kommen genügt natürlich irgendjemand dem
ist mich unbedingt eine freundin in
münchen bekannt
findest du das blöd wenn ich habe vor
kurzem habe ich immer gedacht
endlich macht nägel extension mit zähne
blitzen irgendwas an der haut verändern
operationen dachte immer so eine gruppe
von menschen die das macht und
unterwerfung der gruppe von menschen
nicht eigentlich nicht leiden konnte
oder eingeatmet habe mittlerweile
vereine verurteilt weil mega mega und
mittlerweile habe ich mir auch mal die
fingernägel machen lassen und jetzt hat
die haare verlängern lassen
ja und ich verstehen mittlerweile den
sprach dahinter meint es irgendwie auch
eigentlich im winter fand jetzt auch
nicht die natürliche haarfarbe von allen
leuten oder auch eine sache
genau so hague meldung nach der ja ich
mache vom arbeitsmarkt halte ich find
halte ich das macht auch was mit der
persönlichkeit oder wie man nach außen
hin wirkt und es bedeutet nicht der typ
der immer die gleiche person sein
möglichst was mich ein bisschen
entdecken
ich möchte ein bisschen ausprobieren und
dazu gehört halt auch einfach dass man
seine aussehen verändern
praktischerweise wenig rückgängig
gemacht werden kann ist eine andere
sache
über eine grenze ja aber ich bin jetzt
theoretisch wenn wir fuhren alkohol beim
kopfschüssen wie die ebner aus italien
weiß würde sich darüber aufregte zeit
irgendwie würde man sollte sich
prinzipiell nicht über leute aufbringen
sachen verändern sind egal ob dicker
werden dünner werden auch im thema das
ist bei ihm geblieben
mit magie mirella wieder er hatte wieder
hungern aber letztlich gedacht sagen
dass man sich einfach selbst und seinem
körper wohl fühlt und hört halt jetzt
wenn du dich wohler fühlt weil du lange
hat man macht es doch einfach schwierig
sein
man merkt man bei manchen leuten das ist
ohne gewissen die krankheit ganzer denkt
man im app store zu necken und ich fühle
mich damit einfach nicht wohl und ich
hätte gerne voller rücken und die haben
die lippen aufspritzen lassen was ich
will unbedingt aus dem weg
stimmt bei den anderen unterschied ob
man sagt ich will mich erhoben
genau
mich gut fühle und dass mich dadurch auf
ein paar sachen den charakter angriff
könnten die japaner einfach oder ein
anderer hat ob ich sagte 'ich möchte
zeit mit kalidünger aus dem all dieses
quartier größten 2 und genau bei diesen
vermögende kurz rückt regeln das amt
eher langfristig langfristig halt wohl
fühlt so wie du bist meine leistungen
ausdrücken haben zum beispiel auch haben
monaten erfahren will die halt einfach
wieder nach einem jahr und danach wieder
so wie es war wenn komplikationen
auftreten
wir haben einfach unsere fahne weil du
ja auch gemeint hast du hast vor kurzem
noch ganz anders rüber nach verlassen
nicht irgendwas falsch das ist mein
auftrag das man halt auch reales klugen
musst du ja ich hab früher das gedacht
aber wenn wir verändern und sondern wir
lernen sie mehr dazu kann man auch mal
ehrlich eingestehen
es war vielleicht ein blöd was ich
gemacht was besagt etwas gedacht haben
das findet auch total wichtig einfach zu
zum wachstum der persönlichkeit
irgendwelchen hat sich auch verändert
und auch in sachen kunden die man
vielleicht sich auch auf eine reaktion
von anderen leuten hinhaltens und
überlegt so was sind die beweggründe
kann ich das dann vielleicht nach was
sind denn weil man sagt ja auch immer
wert sich die brüste vergrößern lassen
aber die habt ihr auch so klein
das ist dann okay aber wenn dann jemand
mit preisen nicht mit großen größen
wirklich gebucht und das ist dann schon
wieder schlimm weil das ist ja total
leute sagen ja aber das war so
ästhetisch war die hatte wirklich
kleinen brüste es gibt von ja gar nichts
damit zu tun ob klein oder gemeint aber
in dem moment diskriminiert halt alle
anderen leute die halt aus einem anderen
grund
für den moment genauso schlimm oder
wichtig ist wie ich hatte sehr kleine
brüste und deswegen wollte damit machen
was den ärger ist man auch warum sich so
viele fremde dafür interessiert kann
absehen wenn ich jetzt meine brüste
vergrößern lassen weil ich eine porno
karriere starten will
dann hat es auch niemanden auf anzugeben
genauso wie wenn ich meine brüste
vergrössern würde ich mich mit meinen
kleinen trost mich wohl fühlt
du musst es auch aber ich frag mich halt
einfach wie der belag drauf die andere
aus wenn wir uns vergleichen oder
verurteilen die hammerhart also es gibt
ja immer so eigenschaften die aus der
natur noch an den hängen geblieben sind
wie zum beispiel weißt du dir immer das
schlimmste aus ist es wichtig den körper
darauf vorbereitet dass eine
gefahrensituation kommen könnte
spontane war fällt das zu heiß bescheid
weißt wie du reagieren kann zwischen
solchen sachen und ich glaube das ist
was ganz eng damit verbunden video
anzusehen und gegenüber anfang denken
weil selbst wenn du jemand nicht kennt
muss ja jemanden der schon einschätzen
können um zu wissen ist dann die gefahr
mit gefahren
kann man gehe zwar von natur aus muss
mein körper einfach einschätzen kann ok
musste ich mich von dieser person
schützen oder ist die ungefährlich für
mich das spiel machen war ein release
ist die frau die zürcher alt ist oder es
die sicher ist der mann hübscher als
können oder ist ja wieder eine
konkurrenz würde die nahtstellen
rheinland und turrini und es die leute
so aus wie die auf jeden fall
und vor allem können wir ja auch nur
wenn wir die leute sehen können wir die
ja auch noch vom aussehen her
einschätzen
wir haben eine klare und zu spät dann
wenn man schon um genommen
ich war aber lange her dass irgendwie
bewusstes kannst du ja auch ganz also
klar ist also in dem moment dass du dir
erstmal aber dann kannst du ja klar
denkt ist es aber ich bin ja bereits das
für mich irgendwie vom gegenteil
bedeutet auch immer noch menschen ein
bisschen bedenken im internet geschäfte
für mich ein schwerpunktthema bekannte
leute nicht irgendwie verbieten sich zu
beurteilen
erstens langweilig wird immer jemanden
beurteilt und auf den leuten zu sagen
darf das jetzt mich schreiben dass du
mich hässlich findet oder dass du
findest ich bin zu viel geschminkten
fall hatte er auch mitbekommen haben
sich die leute in einem video beschwert
dass ich einfach zu viel geschminkt
werden dass ich zukünftig aussehen das
video sich das nicht angucken können
hier ist ganz was ungeschminkt ist
niemand da draußen habe ich mich
ungeschminkt gesehen wie mal dass er
mich mal meinem blog oder so denkweisen
ungeschminkt aber daraus gemacht und es
wird halt einfach so ein komisches bild
einfach auch auf das meinen wagen kim
kardashian ist auf diesem foto zu teilen
ungeschminkt und sogar total sind
menschlichen obwohl
einfach seine zeit aber ihre augenbrauen
irgendwie nicht zu stark geschminkt hat
oder keine billig geschminkten glitzer
die schatten brauchen alle achten so aus
es ist ein fake in dem sinne dass man an
man sieht ja auch anders aus wenn man
geschminkte wie auch wenig sinnvoll aber
sonst ganz ohne augenbrauen oder
angemalten haut gehen also vollständig
gemacht nun über dusche lidschatten
maker raus und jetzt ist es halt
wirklich die augenbrauen können nicht
einfach spaß macht macht total spaß zu
tun
wenn ich noch spaß macht also was kann
man damit fahren meist aber auch viele
leute fühlen sich persönlich angegriffen
natürlich im blauen glitzer lidschatten
auf die mieter und sie jetzt deswegen
meinen videos können dürfen
das war ein problem habt ihr schon mal
was gefällt
[Gelächter]
ich mache links und denkt so wird
gezeigt und jetzt gesagt dass ich auf
jeden fall was habe ich denn gefegt ist
[Musik]
etwas an dem wir wirklich du veränderst
auch wach minimal eigentlich aussieht so
traurig die erste von vielen jeweils gut
traurig hast du das ding gemacht hat
warum manchmal so niedlich die gänge
ländern habe man dieses ding gesehen und
brachte es muss ja vom kleinen glas
und ich auch leute angegriffen gefühlt
da machen wir gesagt das was wirklich
beschreiben aber nicht annahm als scheiß
mohammad erkennen angefangen hat das
alle bh getragen haben und brüssel
bekommen haben eine harte partie
ich konnte zu den mädchen die sich
socken in die b haus gesteckt haben dann
immer von der pause zu den sachen wieder
zu rechnen
ich hatte immer so
wo er im märz erding als dann ist das
umso mehr war wie auch gefällt aber
genau andersrum 1er ich habe schon recht
früh gewerbe kommen oder auch mal was
ausprobieren möchte wie es wäre wenn man
das meer immer schlecht ist für mich war
eine natürliche neugier und es ist auch
so in der natur des menschen was
auszuprobieren und wenn es besser ist
dann ist es besser das werden wir ja gar
nicht da wo wir sind
zugleich wenn man länger meint übernahm
in meinem sitz nicht weltbewegend das
was man jetzt plötzlich größere brüste
hat aber mehr weitermachen man sich
konzentrieren kann wenn man nicht die
ganze zeit drüber nachdenkt für kleine
brüste schaffen kann und ich glaube aber
auch alle worte sind da ganz ganz
schlimm
meine schwester ich hab immer gedacht
ich eine kleine nase lang ausgefallen so
dass die leute sich anstrengen wie
gesetzt hat mich sie ganz schlimm
eigentlich wie gras auf der äußerlich
beeinflussbar
der markt braucht auch was die leute
sagen ich habe ein
in der schule oder folge kinder
nachdenke ich mir nie aufgefallen
ja auf jeden fall da muss man echt
aufpassen dass weil solche sachen wie
können alex frei bestimmen da war also
es gibt ja nicht für alle zu aber
beruhigender weise kann man ja sagen
dass es später besser wird oder als man
noch mit 14 15 16
also ich bin immer noch total mir lacht
man wieder aufgefallen ist total und
bündig finden so was andere leute über
mich denken über mich sagen ich weiß es
noch nicht so wirklich ändern liegt halt
einfach in der natur des menschen die
haben wir auch nicht youtube machen geht
es halt auch ihr ziel suchen
diese aufmerksamkeit und einfach einfach
eine gewisse lebensmittel verarbeiten
eingeholt nicht in die mitte aber den
ganzen artikel dazu gelesen dass
tatsächlich die meisten fünf sänger und
abrüsten und wissen was sie auf der
bühne stehen oder irgendwas kreieren die
meisten man muss sich interessierte um
die entwickelt entwickeln so eine
alternative persönlichkeit der dafür
extra zu sein
spielen spielen und dann das die seite
aber ausgeblieben kann weil sich ihr
ganzes leben wollen verdenken du ja ich
bin so zum luder und daher kommen so
diese ganzen künstler und rätsel lösen
bin mal sehr überrascht wenn ben fans
auf einen zukommen fotos machen wenn ich
mich mal so wow du mutig foto zu fragen
ich dann halt so was zu tun
introvertiert und das war ganz einfach
wenn du extrovertiert wird heute halt
deine energie brachte mit leuten
abhängig
und wenn du informiert bist du auch wenn
du alleine bist alles was ich mag und
ich hab spaß aber ich brauche dann
einfach irgendwann auch noch ziemlich
und es gibt leute die vielfalt eher
anstrengend finden alleine zu töten auch
geladen haben findet sie die auch schon
am donnerstag fragen zu meinem
wochenende macht kann sagen einen plan
haben bisher nichts als die psyche und
die facettenreiche psycho dem entscheid
muss ich drei mal korrigieren das
richtige gewinnen
das ist die wahrheit wir können gar
keinen extremen problemen würden
wer auf ein band und ganz mainz ersetzen
sondern immer wieder versagt wenn alles
wieder anders lief die leute sind aber
was für schönheitsideale wie feldmann es
hängt ja auch immer mit
schönheitsidealen wenn man sich auch
überlegt vor zehn jahren war kate moss
noch schönheitsideal die keine haben
total von christina aguilera angeguckt
die war nur haut und knochen
ich wollte ja jeder denkt über als die
dhünn gut wie heute
[Applaus]
viele sagen ja die karten so voll das
unmögliche eingebracht es stimmt aber
immerhin sind die kate moss ist wieder
super schlank sind das ja auch man kann
nicht aber ich trenne diskriminiert zu
heutzutage sich klar zu sagen
ideale schönheitsbild ungesund
das bild was wird übermittelt wurden das
war und gesund wird es heute auch noch
natürlich aber immerhin ist es wirklich
mehr so kommen gesunde ernährung sport
machen
das stimmt so alle instagram leute den
wir folgen
die meisten sind jeden tag im senegal
hat es ist wenn man egal ob drogen
alkohol drogen im sport machen selbst
super gesunde sache wenn du zu
vielleicht kabarett kürze auch durchfall
so weiß man immer auch immer dass man
auf jeden fall von einem eindruck ist
dass man auch behalten möchte das so
sagen kann oder möchte mich auch höhere
drogen und sport machen und ich mache
das einfach von bitten acht gruppen
ich muss mich ausgeglichen ernähren und
links und yoga machen und jahren
stationen der menschlichen kosten dieses
gefühl das kann man auch nicht verhallt
ist durch die social media hat auch so
dargestellt wird als würde das jeder
machen kann man als gruppe aus vergesst
mich unbedingt die pizza die sich
irgendwie
da könntest mal abspecken so weil mir
selber halt nicht gefällt werden
aber ich find's ganz so wie zum beispiel
kostet das ihr zum sport geht sich
dagegen so fakten bilder auch ins akw
man ins disneyland geht und wir brauchen
irland dessen ja letztendlich das
gleiche über jahre das eine vielleicht
ersten schlechten gewissen motivierendes
andere ausnahmen ich will einfach zwei
songs für das gedenken beim sport hat
sich ein ab
ich muss sagen dass ich mittlerweile
echt so im rhein in dem mit mir selbst
in und bekommen auch im alter glaub mir
es ein fake live auf informanten ja ich
esse kein fleisch aber mein instagram
sind halt die besten fünf prozent nicht
fähig in dem sinne wir haben halt auch
wenn man ins becken zwischen ins
programm zieht anguckt nicht das was wir
hier im internet darstellt das ist alles
ist wirklich kleinste prozent an media
montana und das würde zu leben
ich finde
wenn du ein programm zur stelle und
veganes dazu muss man echt halt gleich
ja aber so verhalten hat zurecht aber
warum hat es auch anders sein
die deutschen müssten halt also was
haben die leute davon wenn wir sehen wie
ich keine ahnung in langweiliges
butterbrot
[Musik]
dabei finde ich jetzt aus influenza
richtigen facebook aden instagram oder
youtuber es ist halt so wollen ja
irgendwo die leute unterhalten ob
irgendwer darf nun es findet keine
unterhalten wir uns ein butterbrot ihren
wird das müsst ihr halt auch in
betrachtung sind da um euch den spaß zu
bringen euch zu entertainen und das
einzige was mir machen können dass an
dieser stelle auch wirklich nur zu sagen
dann wird unter weltreise in anfangs
durch um auf thema zurückzukommen sind
nur die fünf prozent unseres ganzen
leben und der ganze rest ist wir gehen
auch passen
aber das will man auch nicht ständig war
das einzige was ich im letzten jahr das
größte was im letzten jahr gelernt hast
du musst dich auch nicht immer
rechtfertigen mitteilen wenn die leute
nicht genau wenn die leute das nicht
weit genug denken können dass sie sagen
und es kann ja auch viele ich war ja
nicht dass es keine checkt und das lernt
man sich auch mit dem alter zu
akzeptieren so es gibt dinge die finde
ich nicht gut aber wenn die anderen das
machen was ich die in ruhe hier stimmt
aus heißt es jetzt irgendwie in meinem
allerengsten kreis und ich mache mir
wirklich sorgen um die person gereiste
das ist wie auch wie darauf angriffszeit
ein schweres thema im allgemeinen
einfach genossen halt einfach alles
nutzen lassen und ja natürlich auch viel
zu viele leute nehmen wachen sie zuerst
und sie selbst auch viel mehr
dann reagieren deswegen auch viel
emotionaler auf dinge die sie eigentlich
mich interessieren wolfen im normalen
leben
jeder denkt in zeiten dieses internet
jeder hat zu dieser zeit dass seine
meinung unserer eltern haben uns wichtig
was man alles werden und gerade auch
durch social media und alles muss hat
manchmal auch dinge wie kommunismus mit
späßchen wurde genau das müssen die
reise dazu und ich glaube auch ich meine
darüber kommen dass wir die schlausten
noch so viel im leben dazu aber ich
glaube dass
[Musik]
dafür schon um ein 17-jähriges ich denke
du dachtest du kennst ja ja ja so ist
das leben
fürs leben aufgeben und auch die fans
können auf die gesunde fähigkeit die
gesunde 55 punkten
die oberen wird noch die große frage ist
defekt
kein kommentar die sachen wie damals als
er auf dem auf dem gerüst tisch saß
wisst ihr noch in seinem orangenen zu
tun die ganzen ablauf kommen bekommen
warum irgendwann will ich anknüpfen
teenie stars wurden halt auch fade
hochgezogen es gibt in denen das
schlimme probleme während einer
geistigen entwicklung gehabt entwicklung
dieses jahr in die weiteren 16 und fand
ihre superstars
wenn du da halt dann noch so oder so
trafen einen teureren einfluss ist es
schon schwierig da eine eigene
persönlichkeit zu entwickeln
den gleich bei mir letztes jahr hat sich
nicht wirklich wusste sogar bin ich
eigentlich weiß wirklich irgendwie mit
17 angefangen auf youtube zu machen und
bis 23 durchgezogen haben letztes jahr
der knackpunkt kommt dann nehme ich
dachte ich bin einige sind hier nach
draußen immer noch mein 17
mehr ich gar nicht mehr als gibt und
natürlich eigentlich das mache ich ja
anfangen ich glaube noch ganz viele
leute ein alter brauch ich auch als zeit
einfach auch eine art fake navi stellt
für dich anderen gegenüber reals
youtuber sondern bist du wirklich die
person die du bist wenn du feiern geht
oder wenn du mit deinen freunden abhänge
und vor allem auch andere wenn ich mit
einer person länger wenn ich bei der
abwasser ich passe mich dann eher dem
vibe die baron und wenn ich mit einer an
paroli ganz europa ganz anderen ecke
kommt ein klassespiel seite wieder mehr
warten auf mich ja aber die fläche
verloren in denen ich einfach wirklich
das gefühl dass ich kann so
hundertprozentig so gar nichts mit
freunden oder wenn man vertraut würde
ich jetzt ein paar marken waren ja muss
einfach auch so haben oder dass du
einfach das andere nicht denkbar ist
alles machen lassen anders irgendwie es
gibt sicher leute die sind ganz viele
leute kennengelernt
wie viele fachleute branche mit einer
ganzen entertainment branche tony top
leute zu einem ankommen und super nett
sind weil sie irgendwas von ihr wollen
er weiß sie nichts mehr von ihr wollen
fand ihrer gartenfeld oder es auch ein
charakterzug von denen sich einfach
verändern wenn sie etwas brauchen sie
kann ja auch einen charakter für einfach
von der person waren das die leute ja in
dem sinne sind
die ja nicht hatten mit einer person zu
tun sie sehr fest und auf youtube ist
ein bisschen älter und die verleugnet
dass die auf youtube kommen ja meine
worte
solche leute ich denke auch am ende
leute so fähig sind
die schießen sicher irgendwann selber
ins bein weil es einfach du kannst
nirgendwo damit hinkommen dass du das
vorgibt zu sein findet bis da irgendwann
die gemeinde und entweder bist du selber
total bedient
also ich finde es immer noch nur noch
zurück
ja ich habe kaum was in ordnung ist
weil hier hatte aber ich habe mir
gedacht aber mit dem thema ausgefallen
da gibt auch wenn euch gefallen ich
finde sich schmeißen wenn sie euch nicht
gefallen
auf jeden fall als potenz
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
stimme und voller essen
[Gelächter]